[Music]
now listen carefully if the weather is
sunny then wear a cap
if you want to go hiking then get a map
if you picture these two words then it's
an easy decision if there was ever a
time to get down
then this is one if the music is off
then turn it off if the music is on then
turn it up if the music is up then hit
the floor and if you're on the floor
then dance
if and then are two regular words what a
marvelous job they do
if there's a part within if at the start
find out if what's in that part is true
now wasn't that fun you practically
[Music]
if it's finally snack time then have
some fruit
if today is your birthday then give a
toot
you follow my method then it will give
you the know-how if there was ever a
time to get down
then it's right now if the music is off
then turn it on if the music is on then
turn it up if the music is up then hit
the floor and if you're on the floor
then dance
if you're on the floor
then dance dance
dance now
if you're on the floor
[Music]